aquí tenemos 65 bloques y si quieren los
pueden contar los podemos representar
con el número 65 escribiendo el 6 en la
posición de las decenas lo que significa
literalmente 6 decenas y esta es una
decena y esta es otra decena otra decena
otra decena otra decena y otra decena
tenemos 6 grupos de 10 lo que da un
total de 60 y luego tenemos 5 unidades y
las vemos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 y vamos a
escribir esto por acá para enfatizarlo
es igual a seis decenas más cinco
unidades ahora vamos a hacer algo
interesante
empezamos con 65 y voy a restar 40
entonces qué es lo que estoy haciendo
realmente bueno tengo 65 al inicio y
estoy restando 4 decenas y 0 unidades
así que vamos a restar 4 decenas de aquí
restamos 1 2 3 4 quito estas 4 decenas y
cuantas decenas me quedan solo me quedan
dos decenas esto es igual a 2 decenas y
cuántas unidades tengo
sigo teniendo 5 unidades y esto tiene
sentido porque al inicio tenía 5
unidades y le restó 0 unidades entonces
sigo teniendo 5 unidades y esto aquí va
a ser igual lo vuelvo a escribir de este
lado 65 menos 40 es igual a dos decenas
tengo que poner este 2 en la posición de
las decenas y luego tenemos 5 unidades
y escribo el 5 en la posición de las
unidades el resultado es dos decenas y
cinco unidades o veinticinco